des centaines de pièces d'argent et 21
dinars en or retrouvé dans un sac en
tissu c'est la découverte exceptionnelle
révélé l'an dernier sur le site de
l'ancienne infirmerie de l'abbaye cette
bague si giller fait également partie du
butin
elle servait à apposer un saut sur les
lettres et sa présence permet d'en
savoir plus sur son propriétaire elle
doit appartenir certainement un
dignitaire de l'église
ça peut être un évêque ça peut être un
abbé madec quelqu'un qui est de passage
à l'acte unis voilà ça n'a pas plus
d'informations et nous on s'oriente des
crèmes davantage même sur un trésor qui
viendraient qui a été déposé ac unicef
qui étaient cachées accueillis mais sont
alors les raisons c'est ensuite sur les
mines qui viendraient d'espagne
on peut balayer toute cette scène ford y
en a et quelqu'un peut prendre une
altitude pour comprendre l'origine du
trésor des fouilles sont en cours à
quelques dizaines de mètres des lieux de
la découverte
objectif connaître le plan exact du
bâtiment et savoir dans quelle pièce ils
étaient cachés
on sait qu'on est dans la clôture donc
on a à l'intérieur de cette infirmerie
et on ne pensait qu'il était près d'un
mur mais ce mur qu'on a sur une toute
petite
limite enfin sur un tout petit un
certain nombre de m mais on sait pas à
quelle est complètement son orientation
c'est pas avec quelle autre mur il
il fonctionne ça veut dire qu'on n'a pas
le plan du bâtiment dans lequel n'était
trouvée a été trouvé le trésor et c'est
ça qu'on essaye de documenter ces
fouilles vont durer jusqu'à la fin du
mois d'octobre
les analyses du trésor se poursuive son
laboratoire il équipe de recherche dont
plusieurs spécialistes en bijoux et
monnet a maintenant un budget sur quatre
ans pour percer le mystère